This is 99% invisible, but I am Roman Mars. As I'm recording this, Donald Trump took office 975 days ago, and it has been exhausting. Independent of where you are politically, I think we can all agree that the new cycle coming out of Washington DC has been very intense for anyone who has been paying attention at all. One of the reasons for the fervor is Trump's role as a very norm-breaking president. If you like him, this is one of the reasons why you like him. If you hate him, this is one of the reasons why you hate him.
这里是“百分之九十九隐形”，我是罗曼·马尔斯。在我录制这段音频时，唐纳德·特朗普就任总统已经975天了，这让人精疲力竭。抛开你的政治立场不论，我想我们都会赞同，对于任何稍微关注过的人来说，来自华盛顿特区的新闻循环都非常激烈。这种狂热的原因之一，是特朗普作为一个极度打破常规的总统的角色。如果你喜欢他，这是你喜欢他的原因之一；如果你讨厌他，这也是你讨厌他原因之一。
But my reaction to all this was that I realized I didn't really know what all the norms and rules actually were. So I wanted to create for myself a constitutional law class, and the syllabus would be determined by Trump's tweets. This is where my friend, neighbor, and the brains behind this operation Elizabeth Joe comes in. She's a professor at the UC Davis School of Law and she teaches Con Law 101. And since June of 2017, she's been kind enough to hang out with me and teach me lessons about the US Constitution that I then record and release as the podcast, what
但我对此的反应是，我意识到我其实并不清楚所有的常规和规则到底是什么。所以我想为自己创建一个宪法法课，而教学大纲将由特朗普的推文来决定。这就是我的朋友、邻居兼这一行动的幕后大脑伊丽莎白·乔登场的地方。她是加州大学戴维斯分校法学院的教授，教授宪法法101。自2017年6月以来，她一直好心地陪着我，给我上关于美国宪法的课程，然后我将其录制并作为播客发布，名为“什么”
Trump can teach us about Con Law. We call it Trump Con Law, for short. It's had what you call a sporadic release schedule, but it's crazy popular for something that I basically do as my hobby podcast to trick Elizabeth into coming over and educating me. And after a long hiatus, we're back with monthly episodes. So I wanted to reintroduce it to the 99PI audience because you may not know about it and because people often comment that the podcast's calm, historically grounded educational discussion is a soothing salve amidst the chaotic and unnerving political news of the day.
特朗普能教我们关于宪法法的什么。我们简称它为“特朗普宪法法”。它的发布频率可以说是断断续续的，但对于一个我基本上当作兴趣播客来录制、好骗伊丽莎白过来给我上课的节目来说，它异常受欢迎。在经历了漫长的停播后，我们带着月度节目回归了。所以我想要把它重新介绍给99PI的听众，因为你可能还不知道它，而且人们经常评论说，在这个混乱且令人不安的每日政治新闻中，这个播客平静、植根于历史的教育性讨论是一种抚慰人心的药膏。
The creation of the show was very much a reaction to the Trump presidency, but it is not reactionary. I'm presenting two classic episodes of what Trump can teach us about Con Law here today, and if you're into it, I encourage you to hop over to the Trump Con Law feed and download the 30 or so other episodes, including a brand new one about obstruction of justice that we released last week. Even though we reference the news and current events and the latest Trump tweets, we tend to just use them as a jumping off point to talk about constitutional history. So the shows still work whenever you listen to them. First up, here's episode number 10 of Trump Con Law on impeachment, originally released on October 9th of 2017,
这个节目的创作在很大程度上是对特朗普总统任期的反应，但它并不是反动的。我今天在这里展示“特朗普宪法法”的两期经典节目，如果你喜欢的话，我鼓励你跳转到“特朗普宪法法”的订阅源，下载其他大约30期节目，包括我们上周发布的一期关于妨碍司法的全新节目。尽管我们参考了新闻、时事以及最新的特朗普推特，但我们往往只是以此为跳板来谈论宪法历史。所以无论你什么时候听，这些节目依然适用。首先，这是“特朗普宪法法”关于弹劾的第10集，最初发布于2017年10月9日，
which was a time when the mother investigation was still ongoing. Check it out. When it comes to the topic of impeachment, most people know that Bill Clinton was impeached in 1998, and that Richard Nixon avoided impeachment by resigning in 1974. And you might remember from history class that Andrew Johnson was impeached, but you can't remember why, at least I can't remember why. But you've probably never heard of West Humphries, have you?
当时“母舰”调查仍在进行中。来看看吧。说到弹劾这个话题，大多数人都知道比尔·克林顿在1998年被弹劾，理查德·尼克松在1974年通过辞职避免了弹劾。你可能从历史课上记得安德鲁·约翰逊被弹劾了，但你记不清原因，至少我记不清原因。但你大概从来没听说过韦斯特·汉弗莱斯，对吧？
No. Okay. In 1853, President Franklin Pierce appointed West Humphries to be a federal district court judge in Tennessee. That's a trial court judge. Humphries appointment was unsurprising. He was a successful lawyer and a state legislator in his home state. He probably would have faded into total obscurity, except for three
没有。好吧。1853年，富兰克林·皮尔斯总统任命韦斯特·汉弗莱斯担任田纳西州的联邦地区法院法官。那是一名初审法院法官。汉弗莱斯的任命并不令人意外。他曾是家乡一名成功的律师和州立法议员。他本可能会彻底湮没无闻，除了三
things. First, in 1861, Tennessee seceded from the Union, and Humphreys was a big supporter of that. Second, President Jefferson Davis nominated Humphreys to be a judge for the Confederate States of America and the Confederate Congress approved the appointment. Third and most important, Humphreys never quit his old job as a federal judge. He just took the new job and didn't quit the old one. That set him apart from the other 13 federal judges who also joined the Confederacy. For a federal judge who has lifelong tenure, firing is not an option. Impeachment was the only way to get rid of him. So it's no surprise that in 1862, the House of Representatives of the Union, of course,
件事。首先，在1861年，田纳西州从联邦分裂出去，汉弗莱斯是这一举动的大力支持者。其次，杰斐逊·戴维斯总统提名汉弗莱斯担任美利坚联盟国的法官，联盟国国会批准了这一任命。第三也是最重要的一点，汉弗莱斯从未辞去他作为联邦法官的旧职。他只是接受了新工作，却没有辞掉旧工作。这使他与同样加入联盟国的另外13名联邦法官区分开来。对于享有终身任期的联邦法官来说，解雇是不可能的。弹劾是摆脱他的唯一途径。因此，毫无疑问，在1862年，联邦的众议院——当然是联邦的——
issued seven articles of impeachment against Humphries. That included one charge that he helped to, quote, organize armed rebellion against the United States and levy war against them, which is undeniably true. They were our enemies. They were enemies of America. Please remember this. And while Humphreys wasn't required to show up in Washington to defend himself, Congress
对汉弗莱斯发布了七条弹劾条款。其中包括一项指控，即他协助“组织针对美国的武装叛乱并向其宣战”，这无疑是真实的。他们是我们的敌人。他们是美国的敌人。请记住这一点。虽然汉弗莱斯不需要现身华盛顿为自己辩护，但国会
was determined to find him. The Senate's sergeant arms was dispatched to Tennessee to look for him but failed. So the Senate ordered notice of Humphreys impeachment proceedings to be published in the Tennessee and Washington newspapers. The Senate ultimately convicted Humphreys on June 26, 1862, and the shortest impeachment trial in American history. It lasted just a couple of hours. Afterwards, Humphreys continued to serve as a Confederate judge.
决心找到他。参议院的纠仪长被派往田纳西州寻找他，但没有成功。于是参议院下令将汉弗莱斯弹劾程序地通知发表在田纳西州和华盛顿的报纸上。参议院最终于1862年6月26日对汉弗莱斯定罪，这是美国历史上最短的弹劾审判。它只持续了短短几个小时。此后，汉弗莱斯继续担任联盟国法官。
So you might think, why in peach Humphreys, the South had seceded, and the Union had some really important things to do, like when this of a war? Part of the answer is that Humphreys' failure to quit as a federal judge was a threat to our system. How could he simultaneously serve the Union and the Confederacy, not quitting his federal judgeship meant that he could issue legal orders while being openly disloyal to the nation. Impeachment is a remedy for constitutional democracy that's built into our constitution itself,
所以你可能会想，为什么要弹劾汉弗莱斯？南方已经分裂了，联邦还有一些非常重要的事情要做，比如打赢这场战争？部分答案是，汉弗莱斯未能辞去联邦法官职务，是对我们体制的威胁。他怎么能同时为联邦和联盟国效力呢？不辞去联邦法官职务意味着他可以在公开对国家不忠的同时发布法律命令。弹劾是为宪政民主构建的一项补救措施，它本身就内置在我们的宪法中，
an important legal process, even in the midst of a national crisis. Congress had to get rid of them, and this was the way to do it. And it's the possibility of impeachment, however remote, that is emerging again as a possibility for this unusual and norm breaking presidency of Donald Trump. Hey everybody, he's still here, so we're back. This is what Trump can teach us about Conlon. An ongoing series of indefinite length where we take the actions and swaddling speculations about Trump and channel that noise into learning our constitution like we never have before.
这是一个重要的法律程序，即便在国家危机之中也是如此。国会必须除掉他们，而这就是办法。正是这种弹劾的可能性，无论多么渺茫，又作为一种可能性再次出现，针对唐纳德·特朗普这个不同寻常且打破常规的总统任期。大家好，他还在，所以我们回来了。这就是“特朗普宪法法”能教给我们的。这是一档长度不定、持续进行的系列节目，我们将关于特朗普的种种行动和无端猜测汇聚成这股噪声，以前所未有地深入了解我们的宪法。
Our music is courtesy of Doom Tree Records, our professor is Elizabeth Jo and I'm your fellow student and host, Roman Mars. It's the one you've been waiting for, the big eye, impeachment. So what exactly is impeachment and how does it work? You can start with the Constitution itself. Article 1, that's the part addressed to Congress, says that the House of Representatives shall have the sole power of impeachment. It also says that the Senate shall have the sole power to try all impeachments. So what this means is that when we talk about impeachment, it's really a two-step process divided between the House and the Senate. So you can think of impeachment as the phase when
我们的音乐由多姆树唱片公司提供，我们的教授是伊丽莎白·乔，我是你的同学兼主持人罗曼·马尔斯。这就是你一直等待的节目，那个大写字母I开头的词：弹劾。那么，到底什么是弹劾，它是如何运作的？你可以从宪法本身开始。第一条，那是致国会的部分，规定众议院拥有弹劾的唯一权力。它还规定参议院拥有审判所有弹劾案的唯一权力。所以这意味着，当我们谈论弹劾时，它实际上是一个分为众议院和参议院两个步骤的过程。所以你可以把弹劾看作是这样一个阶段：
someone is charged with wrongdoing, that's up to the House. If charges are brought, and these are called articles of impeachment, then it's the Senate's job to conduct a trial of the person subjected to impeachment. In the broad sense, we tend to use the word impeachment as meaning being removed from office, but technically, as was the case with Bill Clinton and Andrew Johnson, they were impeached, they were charged with wrongdoing, but they were not convicted and they both stayed on as president. But impeachment is not just for presidents. According to Article 2, that's the part that's usually addressed to the executive branch,
某人被指控有不当行为，这由众议院负责。如果提出了指控——这些被称为弹劾条款——那么参议院的工作就是对被弹劾的人进行审判。从广义上讲，我们倾向于用弹劾来表示被免职，但从技术上讲，正如比尔·克林顿和安德鲁·约翰逊的情况一样，他们被弹劾了，他们被指控有不当行为，但他们没有被定罪，并且两人都继续担任总统。但弹劾不仅仅针对总统。根据第二条，那是通常致行政分支的部分，
the president, the vice president, and all civil officers of the United States can be removed from office by impeachment. The Constitution has a couple of other specifications too, but it's silent on a lot of details. So when it comes to the law of impeachment, when people talk about what that means, it's sort of a mix of what the Constitution says, plus some rules set forth by the House and Senate, some historical experience, and well, a bunch of unknowns. And part of the reason we don't have answers to a lot of questions about impeachment is because we haven't used impeachment all that often. The House of Representatives has only impeached,
总统、副总统和美国的所有文职官员都可以通过弹劾被免职。宪法还有其他一些具体规定，但在很多细节上却保持沉默。因此，当涉及到弹劾法时，当人们谈论这意味着什么时，它有点像宪法所说的话、加上众议院和参议院制定的一些规则、一些历史经验，以及嗯，一堆未知数的混合体。我们对弹劾的许多问题没有答案的部分原因，是因为我们并不经常使用弹劾。众议院仅仅弹劾过——
that means charged, 19 people, ever. There have only been 16 trials by the Senate ever. And only eight people have been actually convicted by the Senate and removed from office. All of those were federal judges, including West Humphries. So how is impeachment supposed to work? Well, the House has the power to issue articles of impeachment, and that can start in a number of different ways, but at some point the House Judiciary Committee, or sometimes another House committee, will look into the possibility of impeachment. They can decide to conduct an investigation and vote on whether to the possibility of impeachment. They can decide to conduct an investigation and vote on whether to issue articles of impeachment. That leads to the full house voting on it or not.
也就是指控过——19人，有史以来。参议院历史上总共只进行过16次审判。而且只有8人真正被参议院定罪并被免职。所有这些都是联邦法官，包括韦斯特·汉弗莱斯。那么弹劾本该如何运作呢？嗯，众议院有权发布弹劾条款，这可以通过多种不同的方式开始，但在某个时候，众议院司法委员会，或者有时是另一个众议院委员会，会调查弹劾的可能性。他们可以决定进行调查，并就弹劾的可能性进行投票。他们可以决定进行调查并投票决定是否发布弹劾条款。这会导致全院进行投票或不投票。
But it's tricky for the house to know if someone is impeachable. The Constitution says that impeachment can be based on treason, bribery, or other high crimes and misdemeanors. It's that last part of the phrase, high crimes and misdemeanors that can be misleading. It sometimes seems as though impeachment means that if you broke the law, then you should be impeached, but that's not how the phrase has been understood historically. It's pretty clear that high crimes and misdemeanors
但对众议院来说，要弄清楚某人是否可被弹劾是很棘手的。宪法规定，弹劾可以基于叛贿赂或其他严重罪行和轻罪。正是这句话的最后一部分，“严重罪行和轻罪”，可能会产生误导。有时人们似乎觉得弹劾意味着如果你违法了，你就应该被弹劾，但历史上人们并不是这样理解这句话的。很明显，严重罪行和轻罪
doesn't mean that a person can only be impeached for committing a crime. Remember, impeachment exists to protect our constitutional democracy. So even behavior that doesn't break the law but appears to Congress as something that's a threat to our system can count as impeachable behavior. And so if breaking the law isn't necessary, it's also true that it's not sufficient either. So just because, for example, a president breaks the law, that doesn't mean he's automatically a subject to impeachment. Ultimately, it's up to the House to decide what they think counts as a
并不意味着一个人只能因犯罪而被弹劾。请记住，弹劾的存在是为了保护我们的宪法民主。因此，即使是没有违法但国会认为对我们的体制构成威胁的行为，也可以算作可弹劾的行为。所以，如果违法不是必要的，那么它同样也是不充分的。因此，仅仅因为比如总统违法了，并不意味着他就会自动成为被弹劾的对象。最终，要由众议院来决定他们认为什么算作
high crime or misdemeanor, and they only need a simple majority to decide to impeach. Once the House decides to issue articles of impeachment, they inform the Senate. That's when the Senate formally tells the person that he or she's being impeached. That person can appear or not appear. It's up to them. The senate is responsible for conducting the trial. And remember the Constitution's specific about this. There are opening arguments, presentation of evidence, witnesses, closing statements. It all looks very trial-like.
严重罪行或轻罪，而且他们只需要简单多数就能决定弹劾。一旦众议院决定发布弹劾条款，他们就会通知参议院。这时参议院就会正式通知此人他或她正在被弹劾。此人可以出席也可以不出席。这由他们决定。参议院负责进行审判。请记住宪法对此有具体规定。有开场陈述、证据呈递、证人、结案陈词。这一切看起来非常像一场审判。
The senate can then convict that person with the two-thirds vote. The Constitution's specific about this too. If the Senate convicts, the person's removed from federal office, that's it. There's no right to any appeal. But here's the funny thing about impeachment. Well, it looks like a criminal trial. It's really not a criminal trial at all in lots of ways. So think about some of the things that you associate with a criminal trial. A defendant is formally charged with a crime. So in the ordinary world, you can only be charged for breaking a law that is defined ahead of time, tells you what the prohibited behavior is.
然后参议院可以以三分之二的票数对该人定罪。宪法对此也有具体规定。如果参议院定罪，此人将被解除联邦公职，就这样。没有任何上诉的权利。但关于弹劾，有趣的是：虽然它看起来像刑事审判，但在很多方面它根本不是刑事审判。所以想想你联想到刑事审判的一些事情。被告被正式指控犯罪。所以在平常的世界里，你只能因违反一条事先定义好的法律而被指控，该法律会告诉你什么是被禁止的行为。
So in the real world, you can't be tried for generally bad stuff we think you did, but we'll decide on it right before the trial. But that's really what impeachment is. There's no clearly defined crime ahead of time. It's really up to the House of Representatives to decide. And if an ordinary criminal defendant is convicted of a crime, he gets the right to appeal. impeachment has no appeal. And in fact, the courts and the Supreme Court in particular generally doesn't get involved
所以在现实世界里，你不能因为我们认为你做过的普遍糟糕的事情而受审，而我们会在审判前夕才对此做出决定。但这正是弹劾的真实写照。事先没有明确定义的罪行。这实际上取决于众议院的决定。如果一个普通的刑事被告被判定犯有罪行，他有权上诉。弹劾没有上诉。事实上，法院特别是最高法院通常根本不参与
at all. The only real exception to this is when the president is subject to impeachment. When that happens, the chief justice of the Supreme Court presides over the Senate trial. In all other cases, the vice president presides over trial. Of course, there's the funny problem of what happens when the vice president is impeached, but we don't really have any answer to that either.
其中。唯一的真正的例外是当总统成为弹劾对象时。当这种情况发生时，最高法院首席大法官主持参议院审判。在所有其他情况下，副总统主持审判。当然，还有一个滑稽的问题，当副总统被弹劾时会发生什么，但我们对这个问题其实也没有任何答案。
And of course, there's the effect of impeachment. That's not like a criminal trial either. The worst thing that happens to you is that you're gone from office. It's not a prison sentence. In fact, the Senate actually has to vote separately if they want to disqualify you from ever-holding office again. And they don't even have to do that if they don't want to. Take the case of LC Hastings. In 1981, a federal grand jury indicted Hastings who was a federal district court judge at the time, and charges related to bribery. He was acquitted, so he stole a federal judge.
当然，弹劾的影响也不同。这也不像刑事审判。对你来说最糟糕的事情就是你离开办公室。这不是监禁判决。事实上，如果参议院希望永远取消你担任公职的资格，他们实际上必须单独投票。如果他们不想的话，甚至都不用这样做。以阿尔西·黑斯廷斯为例。1981年，一个联邦大陪审团起诉了黑斯廷斯，他当时是一名联邦地区法院法官，罪名与受贿有关。他被判无罪，所以他依然是联邦法官。
There was some suspicion, though, that he lied about the investigation and falsified evidence. So a special committee in the judiciary concluded that Hastings had probably broken the law anyway and recommended to the House of Representatives that he should be impeached. The House obliged, Hastings was impeached, and he was convicted by the Senate in 1989. Couldn't be a federal judge anymore. But, the Senate chose not to vote to bar him from federal office. So what does he do? Four years later, Hastings was elected to the House to represent Florida, Florida's 23rd
然而，有人怀疑他在调查中撒谎并伪造了证据。因此，司法委员会的一个特别委员会得出结论，认为黑斯廷斯无论如何可能已经违法，并建议众议院应该对其实施弹劾。众议院照办了，黑斯廷斯被弹劾，并于1989年被参议院定罪。不能再做联邦法官了。但是，参议院选择不投票剥夺他担任联邦公职的资格。所以他做了什么？四年后，黑斯廷斯当选为众议员，代表佛罗里达州佛罗里达州第23
District. And as a member of that body, representative, all see Hastings, the impeached judge, would later vote against impeaching President Bill Clinton in December of 1998. So let's turn to Trump. So we want to be clear, at this point, there's nothing to suggest that impeachment proceedings are going to begin against President Trump. And remember, Congress has never successfully impeached and removed a president. But there are so many weird, unusual, unprecedented things that have happened since Trump became
选区。作为该机构的一名成员，众议员阿尔西·黑斯廷斯——这位被弹劾的法官——后来在1998年12月投票反对弹劾比尔·克林顿总统。那么让我们转向特朗普。所以我们想明确一点，目前没有任何迹象表明针对特朗普总统的弹劾程序将要开始。请记住，国会从未成功弹劾并罢免过一位总统。但是自从特朗普成为
president that the idea of impeachment has been brought up a number of times. A number of times, like from day one, basically. From day one, yeah, exactly. So, at least since election day. Okay. So, we want to be clear, these are merely theoretical speculation. Twitter speculating type stuff, yeah. There are no actual secret proceedings about impeachment.
总统以来，发生了太多奇怪的、不寻常的、史无前例的事情，以至于弹劾的想法已经被提出过好多次了。好多次，基本上从第一天起。从第一天起，是的，完全正确。所以，至少从选举日算起。好的。所以，我们要明确，这些纯粹是理论上的推测。推特上那种推测性的东西， yeah。并没有关于弹劾的实际秘密程序。
So, there are a lot of questions and possibilities. So one possibility starts with special counsel Robert Mueller. Remember that Mueller has been charged with investigating if there were any connections between the Trump campaign and Russian interference in the 2016 election. Mueller himself was appointed by Deputy Attorney General Rodstein, and not by Attorney General Sessions. That's because Sessions recused himself from the investigation. That, in turn, reportedly infuriated President Trump
所以，有很多问题和可能性。其中一种可能性始于特别检察官罗伯特·穆勒。记住，穆勒的任务是调查特朗普竞选团队与2016年俄罗斯干预大选之间是否存在任何联系。穆勒本人是由副司法部长罗德·罗森斯坦任命的，而不是由司法部长塞申斯任命的。那是因为塞申斯回避了这项调查。据报道，这反过来激怒了特朗普总统，
and led him to call Sessions beleaguered in a tweet. And Trump has already lashed out at Mueller, tweeting in June that the investigation was, quote, the single greatest witch hunt in American political history. So, Mueller, the single greatest witch hunt in American political history. So, Mueller, let's say, might find evidence of some very serious wrongdoing on the part of President Trump.
并导致他在一条推文中称塞申斯为“四面楚歌”。特朗普已经猛烈抨击过穆勒，他在6月份发推称这项调查是“美国政治史上最大的一场政治迫害”。所以，穆勒——美国政治史上最大的一场政治迫害。所以，穆勒，比方说，可能会发现特朗普总统存在某些非常严重的违规行为的证据。
Again, we don't know, but let's entertain that thought. This could be turned over to the House just as independent counsel Kenneth Star did in his investigation of Bill Clinton. Now, the House would have to decide whether any information they had would be enough to merit at least one article that's a charge of impeachment. And even if they did that and that's a pretty big if, there's also the matter of a Senate trial. Would two-thirds of the Senate, that's the necessary number needed, vote to convict Trump,
再次强调，我们不知道，但让我们假设这种想法。这可能会被移交给众议院，就像独立检察官肯尼斯·斯塔尔在调查比尔·克林顿时所做的那样。现在，众议院必须决定他们掌握的任何信息是否足以构成至少一条弹劾条款（即弹劾指控）。即使他们这样做了——这是一个相当大的假设——还有一个参议院审判的问题。参议院的三分之二——这是必需的数字——会投票给特朗普定罪吗？
at this point it's really hard to imagine. Another thing, keep in mind that Trump can't pardon his way out of this. Even with the theoretical but super crazy idea of presidential self-parton, go download episode number three for more information on that one. While the president's pardon power is really broad,
此时此刻，这真的很难想象。还有一件事，请记住，特朗普无法通过特赦摆脱困境。即使有总统自我特赦这种理论上但超级疯狂的想法，去下载第3集了解更多相关信息吧。虽然总统的特赦权力确实很广泛，
the Constitution is actually specific in saying that the president's ability to pardon exists except in cases of impeachment. So that's not going to work. If the Senate acquitted Trump, he remains an office, just like Bill Clinton did. If the Senate convicted Trump, he'd be removed from office. In theory, of course, this presumes that Trump would go along with all of this, that he'd presume the legitimacy of the institutions and the process itself. At this point, I'm not even sure that that's a given. And if the Senate convicted Trump, and he were removed from office, and Trump indeed left
但宪法实际上明确规定，总统拥有特赦的能力，但在弹劾案中除外。所以这行不通。如果参议院宣判特朗普无罪，他将继续留任，就像比尔·克林顿那样。如果参议院判定特朗普有罪，他将被免职。当然，从理论上讲，这假设特朗普会顺从这一切，假设这些机构和程序本身的合法性是理所当然的。此时此刻，我甚至不确定这是否是理所当然的。如果参议院判定特朗普有罪，他被免职，并且特朗普确实离开了
the White House, would the Senate separately vote to bar him from any future office? And if they didn't, could Trump come back as Senator or representative Trump? Again, I don't know if it's realistic, but it's theoretically possible. So to sum it up, impeachment is a check on the presidency, but there are a lot of hurdles to the process, which explains why we haven't done it very often. I can ask you a question then,
白宫，参议院会单独投票禁止他担任未来任何公职吗？如果他们没有这样做，特朗普还能以参议员或众议员特朗普的身份卷土重来吗？再次说明，我不知道这是否现实，但理论上是可能的。总而言之，弹劾是对总统职权的一种制衡，但这一过程存在很多障碍，这就解释了为什么我们不常这么做。那我能问你一个问题吗？
but here's the big hypothetical. If he was convicted and removed from office and not barred from future office, could he actually become the president again? Oh, that's a good question. That's a head scratcher. I mean, presumably he could. That is definitely at least some possibility
但这里有一个巨大的假设。如果他被定罪并被免职，但没有被禁止担任未来公职，他真的能再次成为总统吗？哦，这是个好问题。这是一个让人头疼的问题。我的意思是，据推测他可以。这绝对至少具有某种可能性，
because it is removal from that particular office. So yeah, the Senate presumably would have to ensure by saying you are barred from all future federal offices if they wanted to be specific about that. So remember West Humphreys is removed as a federal judge. Because he took a job as a Confederate judge. He is barred from holding federal office in the future. He still faced criminal conspiracy charges for obvious reasons he did oppose the union. So in 1865 Humphreys asked for a pardon.
因为这是针对特定职务的罢免。所以，是的，参议院如果想对此具体说明的话，推测必须通过声明“你被禁止担任未来所有联邦公职”来确保这一点。所以请记住，韦斯特·汉弗莱斯作为联邦法官被免职。因为他接受了一份联盟国法官的工作。他被禁止在未来担任联邦公职。由于显而易见的原因他反对联邦，他仍然面临刑事共谋指控。所以在1865年，汉弗莱斯请求特赦。
In his pardon request, Humphreys made some unusual arguments, including one that he'd said, well, he wasn't a disunionist per se, but he appealed for a chance to live and die in my native state. President Andrew Johnson pardoned Humphreys in 1865, and as a result, the federal court dismissed the criminal charges against him. President Johnson himself would be impeached and acquitted a few years later in 1868. ["President Johnson's The normal run of the mill way of getting rid of elected politicians is to vote them out
在他的特赦请求中，汉弗莱斯提出了一些不同寻常的论点，包括他曾说过，嗯，他本身并不是一个分裂主义者，但他呼吁有机会“在我的祖国安息”。安德鲁·Johnson总统于1865年特赦了汉弗莱斯，因此联邦法院驳回了针对他的刑事指控。约翰逊总统本人在几年后的1868年遭到弹劾并被宣告无罪。摆脱当选政客的正常常规方法是通过投票让他们下台，
of office, but impeachment is supposed to be like a crisis mode. This is the safety valve, this is breaking the glass saying, we've got to get rid of this person. But it is so difficult, and that's why hardly ever happens. And the only time we've ever successfully removed people are cases of federal judges. So yeah, we don't really have any experience with this, you know, hardly in the nation's history.
但弹劾本应类似于进入危机模式。这是安全阀，这是打破玻璃说：“我们必须除掉这个人。”但它太难了，这就是为什么几乎从不发生。而我们唯一成功罢免过的人都是联邦法官的情况。所以，是的，我们确实没有什么这方面的经验，你知道的，在国家历史上几乎没有。
You think it's only successful with federal judges because people don't care. Because there's no big opposition, political opposition on the other side, probably. Yeah, I think that's right. I mean, I think it's less in the public's eye when there's a federal judge who gets in trouble. And in the case of Alcy Hastings,
你认为它只对联邦法官成功是因为人们不在乎吗？因为另一方大概没有强大的反对派，政治反对派。是的，我想你是对的。我的意思是，我认为当一个联邦法官惹上麻烦时，公众的视线关注得较少。而在阿尔西·黑斯廷斯的案子里，
it's not even that much of a black mark. You get to represent the people in just in a different capacity if Senate isn't careful about it. That was episode 10 of Trump Con Law about impeachment originally released on October 9th, 2017. Another episode of Trump Con Law about the complications of criminally prosecuting a president after
这甚至算不上什么大污点。如果参议院不够谨慎，你甚至可以换个身份继续代表人民。那是“特朗普宪法法”关于弹劾的第10集，最初发布于2017年10月9日。“特朗普宪法法”关于在刑事起诉总统的复杂性的另一集，在
this. In now episode 14 of Trump Con Law called prosecuting a president originally released on December 14, 2017. You might have heard this story before. On August 2nd, 1804, a New York arrest warrant was issued for a man who'd fired a fatal shot in a duel in Weehawken, New Jersey. Now murder was a crime in every state, and dueling was also prohibited in most of them. The accused man fled south from New York to St. Simon's Island, that's an island off the Georgia coast.
此之后。现在是“特朗普宪法法”第14集，名为“起诉总统”，最初发布于2017年12月14日。你以前可能听过这个故事。1804年8月2日，纽约发出了一份逮捕令，对象是一名在新泽西州威霍肯的一场决斗中开枪打死人的男子。当时谋杀在每个州都是犯罪，决斗在大多数州也被禁止。这名被指控的男子从纽约向南逃往圣西蒙斯岛，那是佐治亚州海岸外的一个岛屿。
A few weeks later, a grand jury dropped the murder charge. Instead, the charge was less serious. It was sending a challenge to a duel. In late October of that same year, a grand jury in Bergen County, New Jersey issued an indictment for murder in the same incident. Although those charges were later dismissed, because the victim had died in New York and not in New Jersey. There were hundreds of men who participated in duels in the early days of the Republic, but this one duel stands out. The victim was Alexander Hamilton, the first secretary of the Treasury, and one of the authors
几周后，大陪审团撤销了谋杀指控。取而代之的是一项罪名较轻的指控。那是发出决斗挑战。同年10月下旬，新泽西州伯根县的大陪审团对同一事件中的谋杀罪发出了起诉书。尽管这些指控后来被驳回，因为受害者是在纽约死而不是在新泽西死。共和国初期有数百名男子参加过决斗，但这场决斗脱颖而出。受害者是亚历山大·汉密尔顿，第一任财政部长，《联邦党人文集》的作者之一。
of the Federalist Papers. And the accused, that was Aaron Burr, Hamilton's longtime political rival and vice president of the United States. Burr never did stand trial in New York. And in fact, the very next year in 1805, vice president Burr would preside over the impeachment trial of Supreme Court Justice Samuel Chase in the Senate. Justice Chase would eventually be acquitted
而被指控者是亚伦·伯尔，汉密尔顿长期的政治对手兼美国副总统。伯尔从未在纽约接受审判。事实上，就在第二年即1805年，副总统伯尔在参议院主持了对最高法院大法官塞缪尔·蔡斯的弹劾审判。蔡斯大法官最终被宣告无罪，
and returned to the Supreme Court until his death in 1811. Burr only found himself in temporary legal peril. But another vice president, Spiro Agnew, had it much worse, even though he didn't murder someone. Richard Nixon's vice president first became famous for the phrases he used to attack critics and the media He called them the Nattering-Naybabs of Negativism and the hopeless hysterical hypokondriacs of history. He really liked alliteration and cash Brahms it turns out
并重返最高法院直至1811年逝世。伯尔只让自己陷入了暂时的法律危机中。但另一位副总统斯皮罗·阿格纽则惨得多，尽管他没有杀人。理查德·尼克松的副总统最初因他用来攻击批评者和媒体的词句而闻名。他称他们为“消极主义的喋喋不休的唱反调者”和“历史无望的歇斯底里疑病症患者”。他真的很喜欢头韵，而且事实证明，还喜欢现金贿赂。
allegedly in 1973 Agnew became implicated in a bribery scandal from the time he'd been governor of Maryland. In 1973, of course, President Nixon was facing his own legal troubles with Watergate. Ultimately, Agnew pleaded no contest to criminal charges for failing to record on his tax returns cash contributions he'd received. That's basically tax evasion. Agnew received three years' probation and no jail time, but make no mistake. It was a criminal conviction.
据称在1973年，阿格纽卷入了一桩他担任马里兰州州长期间的受贿丑闻。当然，在1973年，尼克松总统正面临着他自己的水门事件法律麻烦。最终，阿格纽对未能将他收到的现金捐款记录在纳税申报单上的刑事指控进行了不抗辩答辩。这基本上就是逃税。阿格纽被判处三年缓刑，没有入狱服刑，但毫无疑问。这是一次刑事定罪。
On October 10, 1973, when he appeared in federal court, Agnew had his letter of resignation from the vice presidency delivered to Secretary of State Henry Kissinger. Now both of these vice presidents faced criminal charges during their time in office. Neither was able to escape criminal prosecution just because of their positions in the executive branch. Right now you might be asking yourself, that's fine for vice presidents, but what about the president?
1973年10月10日，当他出庭联邦法院时，阿格纽将他辞去副总统职务的信件送交国务卿亨利·基辛格。现在，这两位副总统在任职期间都面临过刑事指控。两人都没有能够仅仅因为他们在行政分支中的职位而逃脱刑事起诉。此刻你可能会问自己，这对副总统来说没问题，但总统呢？
Can a president face criminal charges well in office? And if not, why not? Why does any of this matter? Because president Trump, less than a year in office, may be implicated in criminal wrongdoing that has already ensnared his former campaign manager, a former campaign aide, a former foreign policy advisor, and most recently his former national security advisor. Does the Constitution allow the prosecution of a president? Let's carefully consider another constitutional conundrum that this current crazy year has conferred upon the constituency.
总统在任期间能面临刑事指控吗？如果不能，为什么不能？为什么这一切很重要？因为特朗普总统在任不到一年，可能卷入了刑事违纪，这些违纪已经网罗了他的前竞选经理、前竞选助手、前外交政策顾问，以及最近他的前国家安全顾问。宪法允许起诉总统吗？让我们仔细思考这个当前疯狂的一年赋予选民的另一个宪政难题。
I could totally be vice-president. This is what Trump can teach us about Con Law, an ongoing series of indefinite length where we take the tweets and hopes and dreams and nightmares swirling around the 40th President of the United States and channel that maelum into learning our Constitution like we never have before. Our music is from Doomtree Records. Our professor is Elizabeth Jo and I'm your fellow student and host Roman Mars. First, let's distinguish a criminal prosecution from impeachment. The Constitution specifies how certain federal officials, including the president and vice president, can be impeached or removed from office.
我完全可以当副总统。这就是“特朗普宪法法”能教给我们的。这是一档长度不定、持续进行的系列节目，我们将围绕美国第40任总统盘旋的推特、希望、梦想和噩梦，将这股混乱转化为前所未有地深入了解我们的宪法。我们的音乐来自多姆树唱片公司。我们的教授是伊丽莎白·乔，我是你的同学兼主持人罗曼·马尔斯。首先，让我们区分刑事起诉与弹劾。宪法规定了包括总统和副总统在内的某些联邦官员如何被弹劾或罢免。
The House of Representatives decides whether to issue articles of impeachment. These are formal accusations. If it thinks that the person has committed treason, bribery, or other high crimes and misdemeanors, once that happens the Senate presides over the trial of the person being impeached. Now all this sounds like a criminal prosecution, but it really isn't. Impeachment is different because of the outcome of a Senate conviction. The person is removed from office. That's it. No other consequences. Now an actual criminal prosecution, of course, carries with it a lot of possible, very serious
众议院决定是否发布弹劾条款。这些是正式指控。如果它认为此人犯下了叛国罪、贿赂罪或其他严重罪行和轻罪，一旦发生这种情况，参议院将主持对被弹劾者的审判。现在，这一切听起来像是一场刑事起诉，但它确实不是。由于参议院定罪的结果，弹劾有所不同。此人被免职。就这样。没有其他后果。现在，实际的刑事起诉当然会带来许多可能的、非常严重的
consequences. Prison, fines, probation, things like that. No one argues about whether the Constitution itself considers the president's subject to impeachment is right there in black and white. Article 2 of the Constitution specifically names the President as one of those people who can be subjected to impeachment, conviction, and removal. We've never seen the whole process happen before, but President Andrew Johnson and Bill Clinton came pretty close, both were impeached by the House and tried by the Senate. Nixon, of course, resigned in 1974 after the House Judiciary Committee approved three articles of impeachment, but before the House as a whole voted on them. Now, what about the criminal prosecution of a president?
后果。监禁、罚款、缓刑诸如此类的事情。没有人争论宪法本身是否认为总统是弹劾的对象，这黑纸白字写在那里。宪法第二条明确指定总统为可以遭受弹劾、定罪和罢免的人之一。我们以前从未见过整个过程发生，但安德鲁·约翰逊总统和比尔·克林顿非常接近，两人都遭到众议院弹劾并在参议院受审。当然，尼克松在众议院司法委员会批准三项弹劾条款后于1974年辞职，但早于众议院全院对这些条款进行投票。现在，起诉总统呢？
While a vice president can clearly be prosecuted, and in fact, they have been, it's not quite clear that the president himself could be. Now if you look at the text of the Constitution itself, there's nothing there that says a president is immune from criminal prosecution. The closest thing that exists in the Constitution's text is actually about impeachment. In Article 3, Section 3, it says that the person removed by impeachment shall nevertheless be liable and subject to indictment, trial, judgment, and punishment according to law. So what most people think this means is that a person who's been impeached can also be
虽然副总统显然可以被起诉，事实上他们也曾被起诉，但并不完全清楚总统本人是否可以被起诉。如果你看一下宪法本身的文本，没有任何地方说总统免受刑事起诉。宪法文本中最接近这一点的内容实际上是关于弹劾的。第三条第三节规定，经弹劾罢免的人，仍应依法承担并受到起诉、审判、判决和惩罚。所以大多数人认为这意味着被弹劾的人也可以
prosecuted separately. But it doesn't answer the specific question of whether a sitting president, you know, someone who's still in office, can be criminally prosecuted, whether impeached or not. The Supreme Court has never decided a case that resolves this question. What we do have instead are legal memos written during both the Clinton and Nixon presidencies that give us some opinions on the subject. They're not binding in a way that a Supreme Court case would be, but because they were
被单独起诉。但这并未回答一个具体问题，即在任总统（你知道的，仍在任的人）是否可以被刑事起诉，无论是否被弹劾。最高法院从未裁决过解决这一问题的案件。取而代之的是，我们在克林顿和尼克松总统任期内撰写的法律备忘录，为我们提供了一些关于这个主题的意见。它们不像最高法院判例那样具有约束力，但由于它们是
written to provide official guidance, they're still pretty useful. In 1998, independent counsel Kenneth Star asked Ronald Rotunda, a well-known conservative law professor and an expert on constitutional law, to write a memo on whether a sitting president, this was Clinton, of course, could be prosecuted. Rotunda responded with a 56-page legal memo.
为了提供官方指导而撰写的，所以仍然非常有用。1998年，独立检察官肯尼斯·斯塔尔请罗纳德·罗通达——一位著名的保守派法学教授和宪法专家——写一份备忘录，探讨在任总统（当然是指克林顿）是否可以被起诉。罗通达回应了一份56页的法律备忘录。
Its basic point was, yes, yes, a sitting president can be prosecuted. Rotunda thought that the president could delay imprisonment, but not the prosecution itself. But there's an important qualifier to Rotunda's memo. He said he was analyzing President Clinton's very specific situation. Keep in mind, Clinton was ultimately impeached for obstruction of justice and perjury relating to the Apologone's case. This was a case that had nothing to do with the presidency itself. Rotunda was saying, yep, Clinton can be criminally prosecuted for those things, too. In fact, Rotunda made it clear and said,
其核心观点是：是的，可以，在任总统可以被起诉。罗通达认为总统可以延迟监禁，但不能延迟起诉本身。但对罗通达的备忘录有一个重要的限定条件。他说他是在分析克林顿总统非常具体的情况。请记住，克林顿最终因与阿波罗岗案有关的妨碍司法和作伪证而被弹劾。这是一个与总统职位本身完全无关的案子。罗通达的意思是，没错，克林顿也可以因那些事情而被刑事起诉。事实上，罗通达说得很明白，
I express no opinion as to whether the federal government could indict a president for allegations that involve his official duties as president. And then there's Nixon, who ultimately resigned because of the Watergate scandal. This of course involved the president trying to cover up the scandal. In 1973, the Office of Legal Counsel in the Justice Department prepared a legal memo that concluded that a president was immune from criminal prosecution while in office. I can see why Nixon wanted that opinion out there. In March of 1974, a grand jury handed down indictments, these are formal charges, against
“我没有就联邦政府是否可以起诉涉及其作为总统的官方职责的指控起诉总统发表意见。”还有尼克松，他最终因水门事件丑闻而辞职。这当然涉及总统试图掩盖丑闻。1973年，司法部的法律顾问办公室准备了一份法律备忘录，得出的结论是总统在任期间免受刑事起诉。我能理解为什么尼克松希望那种观点流传出去。1974年3月，大陪审团对
seven White House sages regarding Watergate. Now President Nixon was named as an unindicted code conspirator. That term refers to a person who's alleged in an indictment to have engaged in a conspiracy. That's an agreement to do something illegal. But that person's not personally charged in the indictment. Special Watergate prosecutor Leon Joworski advised the jury that in his view, a president
七名涉及水门事件的白宫幕僚发出了起诉书（这些是正式指控）。现在，尼克松总统被点名但未被起诉为同谋。该术语是指在起诉书中被指控参与共谋的人。那是做违法事情的协议。但此人并未在起诉书中被个人起诉。水门事件特别检察官莱昂·贾沃斯基建议陪审团，在他看来，总统
could not be prosecuted in these circumstances. In another memo dated August 9, 1974, the same day that Nixon resigned, Jaworski received a memo from his staff answering the question of whether Nixon could now be prosecuted. The memo began with the premise that there was clear evidence that Richard M. Nixon participated in a conspiracy to obstruct justice. So the memo points to reasons why Nixon should not be prosecuted, including a determination that it might just be good for everyone to move on rather than to aggravate political divisions.
在这种情况下不能被起诉。在另一份日期为1974年8月9日（尼克松辞职的同一天）的备忘录中，贾沃斯基收到了来自其团队的一份备忘录，回答了尼克松现在是否可以被起诉的问题。该备忘录以存在明确证据表明理查德·M·尼克松参与了妨碍司法公正的阴谋为前提。因此，备忘录指出了不应起诉尼克松的理由，包括认定对每个人来说，继续前进而不是加剧政治分歧可能是件好事。
But the so-called Jaworski Memoes also raised some reasons to favor prosecuting Nixon. That included the principle of equal justice under law, which requires that every person, no matter what his past position or office, answer to the criminal justice system for his past offenses. In the case of Nixon, of course, it was all moot because President Ford pardoned him on September 8th, 1974. Ford claimed that the tranquility of the nation could be irreproably lost by the prospects of bringing to trial a former president of the United States. Now, if there's any answer to the question of prosecuting a sitting president, it's not
但所谓的贾沃斯基备忘录也提出了一些倾向于起诉尼克松的理由。其中包括法律面前人人平等的原则，该原则要求每个人，无论其过去的职位或公职如何，都要为他过去的罪行向刑事司法系统负责。当然，在尼克松的案子里，这一切都成了学术讨论，因为福特总统在1974年9月8日特赦了他。福特声称，起诉一位美国前总统的前景可能会无可挽回地失去国家的平静。现在，如果对起诉在任总统的问题有什么答案的话，那这就不是
going to come from the literal words of the Constitution. But one accepted form of constitutional interpretation is to infer a constitutional idea from the structure of the Constitution. In other words, we read that Constitution as a whole and think about how the parts work together. In a 2000 memo, the Justice Department's Office of Legal Counsel stated that neither the text nor the history of the Constitution ultimately provided guidance in determining whether
将来自宪法的字面意思。但一种被接受的宪法解释形式是从宪法的结构中推断出一个宪法理念。换句话说，我们将这部宪法视为一个整体，并思考各部分是如何协同工作的。在2000年的一份备忘录中，司法部法律顾问办公室指出，宪法的文本和历史最终都没有在确定是否
a president is amenable to indictment or criminal prosecution while in office. But if a president could be prosecuted while still in the White House, that might violate the Constitution by preventing the president from doing his job. It's that kind of reasoning that has led the Supreme Court to rule that a president can't be sued in a civil lawsuit for the official acts he takes as president. And it's also led the Supreme Court to decide that a sitting president can be a defendant in a lawsuit for things that have nothing to do with the presidency.
总统在任期间是否适合被起诉或进行刑事起诉时提供指导。但是，如果总统在白宫期间可能被起诉，这可能会阻止总统履行职责，从而违反宪法。正是这种推理促使最高法院裁定，总统不能因其作为总统的官方行为而被提起民事诉讼。这也促使最高法院裁定，在任总统可以成为与总统职位无关的事情的诉讼被告。
The Supreme Court made that decision in the 1997 case of Clinton versus Jones. And of course, it was the aftermath of that case that ultimately led to President Clinton's impeachment. So let's get to Trump. Special counsel Bob Mueller has been investigating any possible links between the Russian government and the Trump campaign, an investigation that on May 18, Trump tweeted as the single greatest witch hunt of a politician in American history. On December 1, Trump's national security advisor pleaded guilty to lying to the FBI
最高法院在1997年的克林顿诉琼斯案中做出了这一裁决。当然，正是该案的余波最终导致了克林顿总统的弹劾。那么让我们来看看特朗普。特别检察官罗伯特·穆勒一直在调查俄罗斯政府与特朗普竞选团队之间的任何可能联系，特朗普在5月18日发推文称，这项调查是美国历史上对政治家进行的“最大规模的政治迫害”。12月1日，特朗普的国家安全顾问对向联邦调查局撒谎表示认罪
about conversations he'd had with Russian ambassador, Sergey Kislyak, last December. That plea, which was to a relatively minor offense, has been understood to mean that Flynn has now flipped. In other words, he's cooperating with special counsel Mueller in exchange for avoiding more serious charges. His plea agreement requires his full cooperation. As of today, Trump's former campaign chairman, two campaign aides, and now his former national security advisor, have now all been charged with felonies. So there's at least two possible problems for Trump. First, the statement of facts underlying Flynn's plea agreement said that a, quote,
关于他去年12月与俄罗斯驻美大使谢尔盖·基斯利亚克的对话。这一认罪针对的是一项相对较轻的罪行，被普遍认为意味着弗林现在已经“倒戈”了。换句话说，他正在配合特别检察官穆勒的调查，以换取避免受到更严重指控。他的认罪协议要求他全力配合。截至今天，特朗普的前竞选主席、两名竞选助手以及现在的这位前国家安全顾问，都已被指控犯有重罪。所以特朗普面临至少两个可能的问题。首先，弗林认罪协议背后的事实陈述称，引述
very senior member of the presidential transition team directed Flynn to contact the Russian government. The statement also says that a, quote, senior official of the presidential transition team spoke to Flynn about what to say to the Russian ambassador. We don't know who these people are, but we do know this. Flynn was Trump's national security advisor. If he's receiving a deal to avoid greater or criminal responsibility, then it's because he has information on other people who are at least as important as or who were more important than he was
总统过渡团队的“非常高级成员”指示弗林联系俄罗斯政府。声明还称，总统过渡团队的一位“高级官员”曾与弗林讨论过对俄罗斯大使说些什么。我们不知道这些人是谁，但我们知道这一点：弗林是特朗普的国家安全顾问。如果他通过达成协议来避免更大或更严重的刑事责任，那是因为他掌握了其他人的信息，这些人至少和他一样重要，或者比他更重要
in the White House. That's not a very large group of people. It might implicate President Trump. Second problem. The day after Flynn entered his guilty plea, Trump tweeted, I had to fire General Flynn because he lied to the Vice President and to the FBI. He has pled guilty to those lies. It is a shame because his actions during the transition
在白宫。这不是一个很大的人群。这可能牵涉到特朗普总统。第二个问题。弗林认罪的第二天，特朗普发推文称：“我不得不解雇弗林将军，因为他对副总统和联邦调查局撒了谎。他对这些谎言供认不讳。这真是一个遗憾，因为他在过渡期间的行为
were lawful. There was nothing to hide, exclamation point. Now that's pretty interesting. Remember that President Trump originally justified forcing Flynn out of his position because Flynn had lied device President Mike Pence about his conversations with the Russian ambassador. Flynn formally resigned on February 13th.
是合法的。没有什么好隐瞒的，感叹号。”现在这很有趣。请记住，特朗普总统最初迫使弗林离职的正当理由是，弗林就他与俄罗斯大使的对话对副总统迈克·彭斯撒了谎。弗林于2月13日正式辞职。
The next day, Valentine's Day, Trump met with then FBI director James Comey. According to Comey, Trump said, I hope you can see your way clear to letting this go, to letting Flynn go. He is a good guy. I hope you can let this go. Call me, said he made no promises to Trump. Call me would later publicly testify to all of this in June before the Senate Intelligence Committee.
第二天，情人节，特朗普会见了时任联邦调查局局长詹姆斯·科米。据科米称，特朗普说：“我希望你能网开一面，放过这件事，放过弗林。他是个好人。我希望你能放过这件事。”科米表示，他没有向特朗普做出任何承诺。科米后来于6月在参议院情报委员会前公开就这一切作证。
And on May 9th, Trump fired Call me. If Trump knew, as his December tweet suggests, that Flynn had broken the law by lying to the FBI, and that's certainly a crime, when he asked Komi to lay off a Flynn, could that constitute the crime of obstructing or impeding the investigation of a crime? In other words, did Trump fire Komi for permissible reasons or impermissible ones? Now, if we were talking about an ordinary person, someone who with corrupt intent tries to impede or obstruct an investigation, well, that person
5月9日，特朗普解雇了科米。如果特朗普正如他12月份的推文所暗示的那样，知道弗林通过向联邦调查局撒谎而触犯了法律——这当然是一项犯罪——那么当他要求科米放过弗林时，这是否构成妨碍或阻碍犯罪调查的罪行？换句话说，特朗普解雇科米是因为允许的原因还是不允许的原因？现在，如果我们谈论的是一个普通人，一个怀有腐败意图试图阻碍或妨碍调查的人，那么这个人
is likely going to be guilty of the federal crime of obstruction of justice. But Trump is not an ordinary person to say the least, but what's relevant here is that he's the president of the United States. Just a few days after Trump posted that tweet about why he fired Flynn, it seems pretty clear that people in the White House knew that it did not look good. So on December 4th, the president's lawyer, John Dowd, offered another defense. It's not that Trump personally didn't obstruct justice. It's that no president can obstruct justice under the Constitution. Okay, so let's think about this for a minute. Maybe doubtment that
很可能会犯下妨碍司法公正的联邦罪行。但至少可以说，特朗普不是一个普通人，这里相关的是他是美国总统。在特朗普发布关于他为何解雇弗林的推文几天后，白宫内部的人似乎很清楚，这看起来很不妙。因此，在12月4日，总统的律师约翰·多德提出了另一种辩护。并不是说特朗普个人没有妨碍司法公正。而是根据宪法，没有哪个总统可以妨碍司法公正。好吧，让我们考虑一分钟。也许多德的意思是
it's not obstruction for the president to do things he's already allowed to do, like fire the FBI director or say, hey, dropped his case because we have other priorities. But a more extreme version of this defense sounds a bit like the president can do no wrong, and that seems pretty incompatible with the democracy that no one, not the courts and not Congress, can hold a president accountable, that a president is above the law.
总统做他本已被允许做的事情不算妨碍司法公正，比如解雇联邦调查局局长，或者说，嘿，放弃这个案子，因为我们有其他优先事项。但这种辩护的更极端版本听起来有点像“总统永远不会错”，这与民主制度似乎非常不相容，即任何人，无论是法院还是国会，都无法追究总统的责任，即总统凌驾于法律之上。
It's that kind of thinking that led to Charles I losing his head in 1649. And keep in mind that both Clinton and Nixon had obstruction of justice charges levied against them by the House in impeachment proceedings, or at least the beginnings of impeachment proceedings. And on the other hand, the criminal prosecution of the President, while in office, would be a destabilizing event for the country. The 1973 memo from the Office of Legal Counsel suggested that it might be possible to bring charges against a president, but it offered this note of caution. Given the realities of modern politics and mass media and the delicacy of the political
正是这种思想导致查理一世在1649年被砍头。请记住，克林顿和理查德·尼克松都在众议院的弹劾诉讼中被提出过妨碍司法公正的指控，或者至少是弹劾诉讼的开始。另一方面，在任期间对总统进行刑事起诉将是该国的一个动荡事件。法律顾问办公室1973年的备忘录表明，对总统提出指控可能是可能的，但它提出了这样一个谨慎的注意：鉴于现代政治和大众媒体的现实，以及精致的政治
relationships which surround the presidency, both foreign and domestic. There would be a Russian roulette aspect to the course of inditing the president, but postponing trial, hoping in the meantime that the power to govern could survive. So does the Constitution allow the prosecution of a sitting president for things he has done as president of the United States. The answer is we just don't know for sure. And it's yet another norm breaking question we've had to address in this year of President Trump.
围绕总统职位的关系，无论国内外。起诉总统但推迟审判的过程将具有俄罗斯轮盘赌的性质，同时希望在此期间治理权力能够存活下来。那么，宪法是否允许对在任总统因其作为美国总统期间所做的事情进行起诉？答案是我们根本无法确定。这是我们在特朗普总统这一年中不得不处理的又一个打破常规的问题。
So since the vice president is essentially a president and waiting, is it possible that the fact that two vice presidents have been criminally indicted could be seen as some kind of precedent that could apply to the position of president as well. I think that's hard in part because of the one of the constitution specifically says about the president himself in a way that doesn't refer to the vice president. It says that all of the executive powers shall be vested in in a president. It doesn't give the vice president that same power. The president is also the commander-in-chief, for example. He shall take care to faithfully execute the laws. None of these responsibilities are given explicitly to the vice president. So there's a pretty strong argument in the Constitution. There is something unique and special about that job, which on the one hand makes the presidency incredibly important for a lot of good and positive things.
因此，既然副总统基本上是候任总统，那么两位副总统曾被刑事起诉的事实是否可以被视为某种可以适用于总统职位的先例？我认为这很难，部分原因在于宪法中关于总统本人的专门规定，并没有提及副总统。它说所有的行政权力都应归属于总统。它没有赋予副总统同样的权力。例如，总统也是三军统帅。他应注意法律得到忠实执行。这些职责都没有明确赋予副总统。因此，宪法中有一个相当强有力的论点。该职位具有独特性和特殊性，一方面使总统职位对于许多美好和积极的事情来说极其重要。
But when it comes to wrongdoing of this sort, it raises serious questions of, could it paralyze the country if a president engaged in a crime and we decided that the president had to be prosecuted for it? Is there something to the argument that the criminal prosecution of the president would be so disruptive to make it just a terrible idea, even if it meant that justice isn't being applied equally to every person in the country? If you think about how bad an impeachment process is for the country in terms of riveting our attention to it and nothing else, in some ways a criminal prosecution would be worse because there it's a much more severe potential punishment. And some ways, a criminal prosecution would be worse because it's a much
但当涉及到这种不当行为时，它提出了一个严重的问题：如果总统卷入了一项犯罪，而我们决定必须起诉总统，这会不会使国家陷入瘫痪？关于起诉总统会带来如此大的破坏性，以至于这是一个糟糕的主意，即使这意味着正义并未平等应用于国内的每一个人，这种说法是否有道理？如果你想想弹劾程序对国家有多糟糕，因为我们的注意力完全被它吸引而无法顾及其他，在某些情况下，刑事起诉会更糟，因为那里的潜在惩罚要严重得多。在某些情况下，刑事起诉会更糟，因为这是一个更
more severe potential punishment. And I think, you know, on balance, it's not just that it would be bad for the country. I mean, you could even think of it in terms of being a criminal defendant. Imagine being a criminal defendant and being the president of the United States. There really is no possibility of having a fair trial. Have you, potential jurors ever heard of the president of the United States? Can you imagine finding a juror who'd say, well jurors ever heard of the President of the United States? Can you imagine finding a juror who'd say, well, I know nothing of this alleged wrongdoing. That would be impossible.
严重的潜在惩罚。我想，你知道，总的来说，这不仅对国家不好。我的意思是，你甚至可以从刑事被告的角度来考虑。想象一下成为一名刑事被告并成为美利坚合众国总统。获得公正审判的可能根本不存在。潜在的陪审团成员，你们听说过美利坚合众国总统吗？你能想象找到一个陪审团成员说，嗯，陪审团成员听说过美利坚合众国总统吗？你能想象找到一个陪审团成员说，好吧，我对这种所谓的错误行为一无所知。那是不可能的。
And that's a central tenet of the criminal justice system that we'd want to have a fair and impartial jury. It's really hard to think of a scenario where we'd have such a fair trial being accorded to the President. Like, if we're going to place bets, I just don't think this is gonna happen. I mean, I think it's far less likely than impeachment, which itself is pretty unlikely. But it raises the question in part because we're, you know, think about the president's lawyers argument that the president cannot obstruct justice because he is the chief executive official
这是我们希望拥有公正陪审团的刑事司法系统的核心原则。很难想象会有一个场景，能够给予总统这样一场公正的审判。就像，如果我们下赌注，我只是认为这不会发生。我的意思是，我认为这远不如弹劾可能性大，而弹劾本身可能性就很小。但它提出了这个问题，部分原因是我们，你知道，想想总统律师的论点，即总统不能妨碍司法公正，因为他是首席行政官员
of the United States. That's a remarkable argument. And even if we just debate it in the press, it's worth thinking about. I mean, do we want a president who believes that? That's the question. No. That's an easy debate for me.
美国。这是一个非同寻常的论点。即使我们只是在媒体上争论它，也值得思考。我的意思是，我们想要一个相信这一点的总统吗？这就是问题所在。不。对我来说，这是一个简单的争论。
That's the easy debate for me. Prosecuting a president was originally released on December 14, 2017. This show is produced by Elizabeth Jo, Chris Baroube, and me Roman Mars, and by his online at trumpconlaw.com. All the music in trumpcon law is provided by DoomTree Records, the Midwest hip-hop collective. The theme song and outro music that I'm talking over right now is by the band Shredders. Featuring Laserbeak, POS, Paper Tiger and Sims. They have a new album out right now. This is me in the present day of 2019, telling you there's a new album out right now.
对我来说，这是一个简单的争论。《起诉总统》最初发布于2017年12月14日。本节目由伊丽莎白·乔、克里斯·巴鲁贝和我罗曼·马尔斯制作，其网址为trumpconlaw.com。《trumpcon law》中的所有音乐均由中西部嘻哈集体DoomTree Records提供。我现在正在谈论的主题曲和片尾曲是由Shredders乐队演奏的。由Laserbeak、POS、Paper Tiger和Sims主演。他们现在出了一张新专辑。这是2019年现在的我，告诉你现在有一张新专辑。
It is excellent. It's called Great Hits. Get on it, people. It is so good. You can find out all about DoomTree Records. Get merch and learn about current tours at DoomTree.net. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, supported by listeners, just like you. A brand new 99PI episode will be out next week. Talk to you then.
太棒了。它叫《Great Hits》。大家买起来。太棒了。你可以在DoomTree.net上了解有关DoomTree Records的一切。购买周边商品并了解当前的巡演。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的自豪成员，由像你这样的听众支持。全新一期的99PI将于下周播出。到时见。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。